Welcome to the Anna and Ashley's show. I am Ann. I'm Ashley and before we get to today's episode
please make sure you like, subscribe and if you're on YouTube hit the little notification button,
so you are sure to never miss an episode. And on today's episode we are going to be talking about
anti-inflammatory drinks. So some fun options. If you're anything like me you get very bored with
drinking plain water and it's just not fun. So we'll be nice and fun options that are going to be
have some health benefits as well. So over here we have an apple cider spritzer and then over here
we're going to be playing together a pumpkin pie smoothie. So some of the anti-inflammatory
benefits of this particular drink is the pumpkin that's in it. So pumpkin is really rich in vitamin A
which is really good for our eye health, our gut health, skin health as well. It is rich in
fiber so it can also help your digestive system. It can help balance your blood sugar levels.
It also is nutrient dense low calorie so it can help support or promote weight loss and then curve
the appetite. It also is rich in antioxidants so it can neutralize free radicals which can be very
damaging to our cells. And then it also has vitamin C in it so it can help with your white blood
cell production and really boost the immune system. It is also 94% water.
Nice! So wow! I have one little can, one can.
Well the other can. Oh yeah! I'm just going to say two. Organics.
Yep and then the BPA free. Yep, white. So the lines of the can. So those are important to
your selecting its organic as well. But not all of our ingredients are organic but the best you can
get better. The other thing in this ingredient list is cinnamon which is very anti-inflammatory.
It has is also rich in antioxidants. It can help us fight off infections as well. So a couple
other bonus things. Yes, sounds delicious. I can't wait to get to that one. For the apple cider
spritzer so kind of the ingredient here, the powerhouse here is going to be the apple cider vinegar
and the active ingredient in here is the acetic acid. So in scientific research acetic acid has
been shown to kill bacteria or prevent bacteria from multiplying. So that's really important.
The apple cider vinegar has also been shown to reduce insulin spikes. So after you have a meal or
after you eat something that's higher in sugar, you can have those insulin spikes and the apple
cider vinegar will help curb that spike. So that helps because that contributes to the inflammatory
response when you're constantly having those insulin spikes. It's also been shown in studies to help
similarly to the pumpkin to help satiate people and to help people feel full. So they will eat less
calories. So it can be used as a weight loss tool. And it's also been shown again like pumpkin to
support heart health in reducing triglycerides, reducing cholesterol and improving blood pressure.
So very heart healthy. And then it's also rich in polyphenols, which are antioxidants. So
like pumpkin as well, helpful to prevent DNA damage to cells. The other star ingredient here
is the manuka honey. And this is antimicrobial antibacterial and really an immune powerhouse.
So yeah. So those are going to create a drink as well. So first, what we are going to do for the
smoothie is a half of a cup of unsweetened canned pumpkin. Okay. The shining ingredients. Yes.
Which this is organic and BPA liner great. So even with any of your ingredients, if you can get them
organic, that would be in your best interest. We do not have all organic here unfortunately. But
okay. How much are you so half a cup? I don't even like pumpkin pie, but I feel like I like this.
Yeah. I love anything pumpkin. Okay. I did like a cup. Yeah, you did.
You did a lot. That's all right. All right. That's more pumpkin than better, right?
Then if it's come from the pump. Yeah. So we need to double up on the center. Yeah, too.
Okay. Next is the nut milk. So one cup. So okay. We picked almond milk for our nut milk.
Okay. So whatever one you think is best coconut milk, it might be actually pretty good too.
Yeah. Three ice cubes. Three. Three. Is that part? Two or three at a time. Okay.
Okay. So all the sides. They're stuck together.
Two heaping tablespoons of the almond butter. Okay. Oh god. That is more.
I think that's just better. We both do a little bit more and not so much heaping because then it's like
and it's equal. Yeah. Yeah. We're upping everything because we started off with a lot of pumpkin.
So there you go. Okay. Then we have one teaspoon of cinnamon. You're going to have a cinnamon taste
when you're stirring. I like cinnamon so it's fun to eat. One of those. Cinnamon's very on the
power. I also don't want to add too much. Yeah. And then we have teaspoon of the nutmeg.
Okay. And a teaspoon of the maple syrup. Okay. Again, this is, that's just for cookies. Yeah.
This is a hundred percent pure maple syrup. Perfect. Don't get the high fructose
imitation maple syrup. Yeah. And then... Okay. One teaspoon of the vanilla extract.
Okay. You go. I know I'm a pro. Yeah. This is cooking show. The best sponsor me.
Rachel Ray level. Nice. Food. Now we're here. Here we come. All right. Real,
simple cooking. Yes. Not really cooking. Lending. Lending. Okay. You got it. All right.
Too bad we don't have enough. Oh my gosh. The finished product.
Yeah. Unfortunately. So we're going to blend. Plug your ears. It's loud. Do you like your glucose?
The ananas. It's official. Okay. And you can also add. Since it's like pumpkin pie.
Some ready-whip. This one's dairy-free almond milk. Cheers. Okay. This actually
tastes like pumpkin pie. Oh my gosh. That's awesome. Okay. Me too. Yep. That could be my afternoon hydration.
Okay. All right. So next roommate, Anne's apple cider sponsor. Yes. Okay. Okay. I'm going to do it.
So we're going to do eight ounces of sparkling water. Okay. And we are using pellet right now here.
And you're going to pour this over. Right. Okay. And then you're going to do apples cider vinegar
at one tablespoon. Okay. I like to shake it up a little bit first. We're going to do it. So the
mother incorporates throughout all of it. Sounds nasty. That's good. How much? One tablespoon.
Okay. That's pretty potent too. Yeah. That flavor. Okay. One tablespoon. And then one tablespoon
of freshly squeezed lemon juice. Me too. And what if you just put like a slice of lemon in there?
You're going to do both. Yeah. Squeeze it in a little like that. I like real lemon juice. Me too.
So this is what I do. I'm going to add like ketchup and slaves in there. Just for garnish. Yes.
Okay. How much lemon juice did it say? One tablespoon. Okay. That was probably more, but that's
right. Okay. We'll garnish our cups. Perfect. All right. What's next? Next is few drops of raw honey.
Okay. Raw honey coming up. That smells strong. Let me love lemon. Me too. Okay. A few drops.
So yeah, obviously they are all. It's not a mango honey. Yeah. Okay. There's a dollar. That's like
a jiffy drop of raw. Instead of a drop. Okay. And that's it. Pour it over ice first serving.
Okay. Yeah. Let's go mix it. Of course. Here's your mixing spoon. Okay. Thank you.
Put that in a cup right here. Then we're going to garnish. Okay. Here we go. Okay.
So it's going to be good too. This. I can see sipping around the pool. Poolside, zipper. Yes.
Cheers. I really like it. It's really is like a legit spritzer. It is super refreshing. I think these
would be perfect for like Thanksgiving get-togethers for a non-alcoholic beverage. Yes. I mean,
this is good. Yeah. Really good. I love the bubbles. Yes. I'm a carbonation girl. I like to have that
bubbly fizzy. Yes. So yeah. Yeah. It's great. So hopefully these will be something that you can
incorporate. Maybe into your Thanksgiving meal or anytime that you're bored with. Let's just water.
And some planetary drinks. And planetary drinks. Thank you. We'll see you in the next episode.
Cheers. I like this one too.